what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to hate videos that were
made about me I had no idea that people
hated me on the internet none I was
shocked and odd until my producer
blessing
um showed me some hate videos last time
so since you guys got 10 000 likes on
the last video we are going to be doing
another one so make sure you like the
video
um how many likes do we need this time
to do a third one um if you guys want us
to do a third one we need 15 000 likes
so let's get started we're comparing you
is she talking about us
whoa it's an awful lot of hate but I'm
gonna come back at you with love even
though I want to be so petty right now I
won't be because clearly hurt people
hurt people so you must be just oh the
who hurts you who hurt you no one hurt
me no no I can't say this anymore I was
gonna say this in the sea
it doesn't see her being compared to fix
but I can't say that anymore nobody hurt
me this wasn't because of anything I'm
sorry men don't like chicks I'm not hurt
that just is what it is miserable right
now so I'm gonna give you some love I
genuinely hope they pick you
I was like you once I lost a ton of
weight
and and you should have kept it off
why'd you gain it back
maybe if you're in my mentality you
would have kept it off this is what
happens fellas fellas it is not about it
is not about how she looks it is about
well it starts with looks but look at
look it mentality is important and you
can have a thin girl in shape but if she
has that mentality she's just gonna gain
the weight back she's gonna get it back
they picked me and I was miserable but I
ended up finding myself
finding myself we know what that means
myself and spreading love instead I hope
the same for you she spread a lot of
love I'm sure you might not get the same
outcome but I hope they pick you But
ultimately I hope you heal that poor
little injured girl inside of you that
feels the need to attack everybody else
around her
I don't feel the need to attack everyone
only pics you hear that part because she
she needs a hug she needs some love I
hope you heal her but until then just
leave people alone my God name someone
that looks good at 300 pounds 300 pounds
isn't healthy it doesn't look good
nobody looks good
making Tick Tock videos
slamming other people's bodies whose
medical situation or lives you know
nothing about every single 300 or so I'm
sorry 300 is a lot there is no medical
condition that makes you 300 pounds I
swear to God I swear to God I don't need
a doctor's degree I don't need anything
medical to tell you that 300 it's too
much ladies like men aren't asking for
Perfection they're not asking for
Perfection but Jesus okay Kobe you
smashing girl at 300 pounds blessing you
smashing girl at 300 what about 250.
yeah yeah okay okay we need to get it
keep it under 250 guys
on this Earth
is dealing with their own struggle
some people's struggles are visible
some people struggles aren't visible
when we look at you your struggle isn't
visible but that doesn't also she thinks
I'm pretty she thinks I'm pretty I mean
that you are better than other people
you know it's crazy anyone that deals
with me in real life knows I'm actually
very polite I'm actually very polite I'm
actually not mean at all but 300 is a
lot ladies it's a lot I'm not asking you
to look perfect all the time but I think
it's perfectly reasonable reasonable to
say you know what we should keep it
under 300. whose struggles are visible
but see now that you've opened your
mouth your struggle is becoming a parent
because you have to punch down
in order to feel good about yourself
because you're insecure
and you know
you're so insecure shame insult guilt
need to be right modern women everybody
a lot grosser
than someone who's just overweight
actually I have a question for the men
in the room okay I'm gonna guys they
don't have Mike so I'm just gonna tell
you what their answers are would you
rather take a 300 pound girl that's very
nice
or a girl that's 120 that's a little bit
mean
he says 120. look it so I honestly I'm
just being real here I'm just being real
they both said 120 it doesn't matter if
you can't fit through the door because
you're so well no one looks good at 300
pounds
um you should probably lose weight do
you hear that
oh no it's like the front stomach
oh
okay yeah it's I don't know I hear a
ringing or something
oh
okay
yeah I guess it was nothing
whatever
just ignore me like these that is coming
your way you can't ignore that you can
ignore me but you can't you can't ignore
high cholesterol heart disease diabetes
can't ignore that I keep doing what
you're doing it seems to be working for
you
ew stop such a gynocentric social order
and when I first heard this I was
thinking there's no way
when people talk about privilege
and how people in high levels of
privilege
don't see the world
the same way the rest of us do
this is what they're talking about
she's white splaining
as someone who has tried
to participate in all those programs
she's talking about
who has been homeless
who has tried to get money from an
extremely abused man who has tried to
prove that to a flawed court system
and I'm [ __ ] white
it's in my favor oh my goodness Lady
Lady Lady Lady this is
when you blame the world for your
problems like take some ownership why
are you in these situations why does
every bad situation happen to you it's
probably you're the common denominator
in all of these situations if your
relationships are [ __ ] your money
situations [ __ ] you you have no friends
or family you can go to you know it
might be you I'm not I'm not a PR I'm
not a detective but [ __ ] if you if
everything all these different areas of
your life are going wrong it might be
you it might be I'm just saying you have
no [ __ ] idea what you're talking
about sweetheart
you have a lot of Education to do
name someone I like how they say you
have a lot of Education to do but they
don't educate me it's like if I don't
have if I need to be educated give me
the education what did I say that was
incorrect are there are there more men's
shelters than women's shelters no no how
many men's shelters are there in the U.S
not many 300 pounds 300 pounds isn't
healthy it doesn't look good
I I know what you're doing I see what
you I see you I've seen the scenario
dozens of times okay this is bait like
you're trying to go to a bunch of
plus-sized people into getting into
their hottest little outfits to show off
for you well please don't do that please
please don't do that please don't do
that no screw that you're not getting my
goodies for free
oh no
ah I missed out yourself fellas focus on
yourself ladies it's weird because oh my
God it's always they always have a voice
that's two octaves too high every time a
guy criticizes me it's never octave get
your testosterone levels checked sir sir
your whole brand
is about not minding your own business
like how is somebody who has become
Tick-Tock famous for fat shaming
has the nerve to tell others to mind
their own business
and you're absolutely right it was rude
I'm getting mansplained I'm getting
mansplained right now he doesn't even
know my my Tick Tock career I almost won
a national TV for relationship quizzes
that had nothing to do with ticks swear
to God I almost I had house tour content
but this is what this is what the
mansplainers do to minimize women's
accomplishments ah the oppression oh
it's so hard people telling you that
your face is ugly and that you're ugly
in general isn't what makes it true
you're just salty because the whole
world doesn't agree with you and you're
some sort of like oh
yeah self-image time it seems like you
have a lot of options sir I'm sure the
ladies are just lined up that people
just want to be you
like I don't even understand why
somebody being overweight bothers you
it's not like you're worried about
People's Health you just think you're
better because you're skinny and you're
not
I think I'm better at nutrition than
someone that's 300 pounds I never said I
was perfect I'm addicted to Sugar coffee
okay but I I would say I'm in a better
place than someone that's 300. name
someone that looks good at 300 pounds
300 pounds isn't healthy it doesn't it's
not healthy to be so [ __ ] hateful
it's probably worse for your heart than
my cholesterol when it comes down to it
with that said y'all can y'all teach me
how to see the Stitch videos that
because there's probably a whole bunch
of women over 300 pounds making her look
stupid as [ __ ] showing how good they
look and I don't make me say it put the
blubber Away Ladies please don't
follow slam from you know
scientific purposes childhood don't
[ __ ] get nosy on me actually I think
this is the first guy that hasn't had
like a a voice that's super high your
uncle's allowed to be like this I ain't
married
you know shocker even if I was married
she'd probably be okay with it but
getting back to it you know
you know I'm into women you know I mean
if more women's like more pizza what the
[ __ ] you mad about the pizza was a
little bigger if hitting the car didn't
it what the [ __ ] you mad about it's at
your house right are you not gonna eat
it because it's bigger you're not gonna
eat the pizza because it's bigger the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
come on now what do you want [ __ ]
Tostitos now I want that Bell delivery
pizza okay okay I'll give you an analogy
okay some guys might still eat the pizza
I mean it's there right
it's available it's usually not that
hard
um however however they're not gonna a
giant ass Pizza they're not gonna put it
at the front of their Cuisine they're
not gonna show it to all their friends
they might you know when no one's
looking but
ah you know I'm wrong men love girls
that are 300 pounds I'm wrong yeah yeah
I'm just wrong
I was I've been over 200 pounds and I
knew I didn't look good and so I
bestie I'm 200
. I'm just curious guys she's not bad
smash or pass okay pass okay they both
said I was I was rooting for you on this
one girl I mean she's like uh I don't
know sounds like
you're a problem
everyone that is using my sound but I
said
but you want to say thank you Tess for
using your sound you're welcome honey
because I scrolled your IG page and
fat girl fashions out here [ __ ]
winning so if you needed some help with
that you should have just said so you
ain't have Shameless on the internet
I'm sorry I can't take fashion advice
from someone that has like I don't even
know what piercing that is would you
guys date a girl that had a piercing
like that no no what if she was really
really hot wait maybe
but okay we got 50 50 on the piercing
I'm sorry I just can't I don't I don't
like this type of piercings look it I do
wear my mom's dresses sometimes I'm
trying to I'm trying to stop with that
okay this is a new Leaf
um however it doesn't matter what I wear
okay I'm gonna look better than someone
that's 300 pounds that's a lot also let
me throw this out there you were so
worried about what fat people are doing
you don't care about us you don't you do
not care for us you speak so poorly of
us and so highly of skinny privilege and
pretty privileged and all these things
so why are we in your mouth it's not
just something that's just given to you
being skinny is earned you have to earn
that it's not it's not a privilege and
the second thing is they take the
podcast out of context the reason I said
that no one looks good at 300 pounds is
because we're having a conversation
about beauty standards and the reason we
were talking about it is because like
every time I I try to talk to women
about objectively what is attractive
what is unattractive I'll use lizzo as
an example I'm like that's not a 10. and
girls literally can't admit that lizzo
isn't a 10 and it's so frustrating
because they'll do the show over and
over and over again and it's like I know
they know that this girl's not a 10 and
yet I still have to explain it over and
over again so big girls man I always be
on the same side when we're together but
when you come for one of us or some of
us you come for all of us that's true
that is true they do stick together when
it comes to anyone calling them I'm like
y'all are so confident with the body
positivity why are you anyway why are
you so triggered someone make sure if
you're gonna stand in the kitchen with
us with the Bingo arms you can have a
piece baby oh
oh that's like that she's gonna be 350.
you tried it have a good day name a
person I don't know if I should say this
it's kind of me but this is kind of the
simp's fault because someone there so
we did have this level of confidence so
it's
it's honestly I'm just I'm just being
real here good at 300 pounds well
I'm back since we wanted to report my
video and have mine taken down I didn't
report anything we're doing the same
[ __ ] thing that you're doing in your
do you not like when somebody else
comments on your appearance I find it
really ironic how wrong you think I got
time to report all the hate videos that
are made about me oh oh gosh usually
over here can willingly dish out insults
towards how other people look and
comment on their appearance but you
can't take I I don't go after things
that people can't change look at it my
face is my face I was born with this but
300 pounds that's a choice that's a
choice you could lose that weight and be
hot tomorrow but you choose not to you
know it's like someone does it to you a
little hypocritical no seems to me like
you can dish it but you can't take it I
got a bone to pick with Tick Tock too
yeah I just I'm just so hurt yeah yeah I
totally know who you are you took down
my video for harassment bullying what
girl I I didn't take dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] is
she doing in hers she's like a rather
large following and you allow her to
spew her fat phobia all over it yet when
I say that she's got a long life what do
you mean allow allow I'm on my fifth
Tick Tock account identical twin I'm the
person
oh that's a good one actually I should
be here for Halloween Look Me and Mrs
wait wrong person we got beef YouTube
tick dog over 200 pounds and I knew I
didn't look good except I'm just about
outside from the get-go in another video
be [ __ ] for real dude
like I swear to God if these women
I don't know what the [ __ ] she just said
but I started out of these women worked
as hard as they do at making these
videos and convincing themselves they're
hot as if they worked that hard at
getting on the treadmill and actually
becoming hot they wouldn't have to make
these videos they would just be hot I I
don't know what this girl said but I
would I would advise getting on the
treadmill I would start there dig they
don't correlate should they do that you
two little fights we're gonna see what
language is this I would hear like words
of English everyone oh a devil that is
using my sound where I said show me
someone that looks good at 300 pounds yo
just proven my point that's all I gotta
say you're just proving my point carry
on name someone that looks good at 300
pounds 300 pounds isn't healthy no no no
no show me show me that you're killing
it and rocking it and looking as Fierce
and fine as you are at over 200 over 300
doesn't matter your weight poundage
truthfully I can tell you without a
doubt like I what I'm about 5'3 I'm over
210 pounds Haram Haram five three or two
ten why did you let yourself get there
and this is these people are so selfish
I swear to God because you if you want
to have kids you're going to pass your
eating habits on to them if you want to
get married okay your husband's gonna
have to take care of you when you're in
the hospital because you're too fat and
you know if you don't get married then
your mom's gonna have to take care of
you your siblings are gonna have to take
care of you or the health care workers
are gonna have to take care of you why
don't you just make better decisions and
put the fork down Deborah put it down
and I'm healthy oh
two ten and five three
wait this is why why do we let these
women live in delusion
um
don't listen to uh tapeworms in the
system
don't listen to people who are just
gonna sit there and try to equate your
beauty to your weight because that's
just
they have insecurities with themselves
and hopefully they can get past that and
get through that in life
I'm not insecure I'm just not blind like
if you're shaped like a bowling ball
that's not a true whatever whatever
you're beautiful it doesn't matter your
weight
it does it does don't let these women
lie to you if if someone wants what's
best for you they'll tell you the truth
if someone wants to feel good they'll
tell you what you want to hear so she
knows damn well that is not true she
knows damn well that the bigger she gets
the less attention she gets she knows
damn well that it's not good for you she
knows damn well she's not happy she
knows damn well she's not satisfied with
the type of guy she attracts but she'll
lie to you as long as you're happy
act like therapists when none of you
have therapy therapeutic I already know
they're going to say something about
nutrition I can feel it
I don't need a therapy degree to know
when someone's an [ __ ] I mean it'd be
cool to know why you're so [ __ ]
hateful
but if you're adamant that there's it's
not hateful to say that overweight is
not attractive that's not hateful that's
just reality I don't make don't make the
rules I just tell you what they are I
wish
that's like me going around to everyone
and saying You must be attracted to tall
gingers I don't whatever reason than uh
I guess the alternative is you were born
that way
so doing that information what you will
born an [ __ ]
why do I want to sing the Lady Gaga song
[Music]
and to everyone calling me a pygmy I'd
rather be a pick me than a skip me I
mean well honey
oh
if you want to get technical you're both
of them oh God smash or pass
I'm gonna get blessing of Mike
[Laughter]
Mike no no no
you're good okay okay what about smash
or pass what am I after five beers no no
way they're shaking their heads I mean
only someone who is rejected by a big
person will talk about big people the
way you do
okay you eat eggs or some other high
protein meal oh my God is it that easy
I'm gonna go get some egg eat some
[ __ ] protein okay eat a donut instead
I'm [ __ ] mod protein I had a Korean
barbecue last night a [ __ ] I named
someone that looks good I'm not
surprised 300 pounds listen I'm not
coming for this girl because the
internet is already doing it so yeah but
I am going to explain to you why people
are coming for you you're using the plus
size Community as a way to build up your
algorithm and bring Revenue into your
page girl I don't need the plus size
Community to do that you think I make
money off of tick tock they're taking
away four accounts girl people watching
your videos people like this is how
narcissistic women are like I have
almost 700 000 followers in six seven
months you think I need the plus size
Community to get views stop it stop it
my video sharing your videos is what's
bringing you money so of course you're
gonna continue talking [ __ ] about the
plus size Community because what we're
bringing you the money babes wow you're
so smart but let me inform you another
reason why people are possible I'm
pretty sure you already know this and
it's because you're just stating your
opinions right and you're just saying
okay well fat people don't deserve love
did you forget
I said nobody deserves love and I said a
fat chick doesn't deserve someone that
makes six figures I've gone over this so
many times it's like
if you guys were both broke overweight
homeless men would you demand Beyonce no
no would you demand Beyonce blessing no
no okay
um see because men have to deal with
reality they don't live in delusion but
for some reason like fat chicks get
offended when you say you don't deserve
a top ten five percent guy I don't go to
the NBA and demand to get in even though
I have no qualifications
but for some reason fat chicks do that
that is not a quality to fall in love
with love is based off of Personality
yeah but it starts with looks for men
like they don't they have to want to
sleep with you first and be seen in
public with you yeah okay or like how
someone is not their physical if you're
probably gonna live with someone's
physical that's called lust babes okay
that's first second of all oh if you're
fat you don't deserve to be with someone
who has money why what if my personality
and what I bring to the table is worth
it I'll tell you when you don't bring to
the table
like guys guys okay in America it's so
easy if you're in shape you're in the
top 20 of women and y'all are demanding
a top 10 man oh my goodness you cannot
Define how much my love is worth where's
your ring where's your ring oh yeah I
think everyone's inside of their own
opinion but you're smart because you're
using us to bring Revenant to your page
congratulations people that are thinner
tend to look better than people that are
bigger
according to who
oh God
I just feel like this is a dead [ __ ]
like beating a dead horse men see how
many matches you get with a supermodel
body like a real supermodel not the ones
they have nowadays and yours see the
quality of guy you attract just just
Let's do an experiment
who hurt you
oh God the who hurts you ah yeah I'm
just so hurt I cried myself to sleep
every night my life is so horrible I
hate you know my awful job where I just
get to make content for a living
um I hate yeah it's just horrible
horrible now
look the same after six months
six months when you get down to it and
you figure out who they really are as a
person that's not true guys do you feel
like all people look the same after six
months yeah just yeah they're shaking
their heads do you think like you could
if if you really got to know a fat chick
that you would really just fall in love
with her no that's for you I'm sorry no
takes for you blessing why are you
laughing
that that is what we should be judging
preference yeah people have a preference
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
imagine if if I said I don't like short
men I swear to God the short man would
not make this many videos if I said
short men don't deserve Victoria's
Secret models some guys would say you're
wrong but they wouldn't do all this they
wouldn't do all this you know I I tend
to go for chunkier people I I
you know but I I love anybody at anybody
size I don't I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
because you're like help healthy and
happy and plus you're looking at this
from a woman's point of view because
here's the thing like women there are
times when a guy if he's even if he's
not the best looking can still win us
over by having like status money
um a good personality whatever but it
doesn't work the same for men
um your personality can help but you
have to be you have to basically be over
his bottom line of Attraction of what he
would be seen in public with who cares
man it's it's really uh it's really who
people how people treat other people
that's that's what matters you know what
I'm saying so sorry for comparing you
oh honey you're confused we're mermaids
not land listen honey listen good no
my manager says I can't call them that
anymore
um but you are a beautiful majestic
creatures yes yes uh not mermaids not
mermaids doing your toxic fat phobia
[ __ ] out in the world isn't helping
anyone you're only the reason the body
positive Community comes at you when you
start why did you do this to me today
blessing why did you do this to me today
viewing your toxic fat phobicate is
because fat phobia kills people that now
diabetes kills people what's the number
one cause of death in America I'm gonna
look this up number one yeah heart
disease heart disease that kill being
kills people phobia causes severe eating
disorders that kill people why are you
so insistent on enforcing your beauty
standard to the point that it's at the
detriment of people's Health do you what
what's more of a problem in society
anorexia when 80 of the population is
overweight in the U.S or seven I don't
know exactly it's like 70. or what what
percent of the population is anorexia
that's not a huge problem I'm sorry
because if it was we would be thinner
and how important mental health is do
you understand how important self-love
is clearly you don't because clearly you
don't have it I came on this app
screaming no I think we have enough
self-love in society I think we should
bring back
humbling these women
[Laughter]
um because it's like look at Instagram
we've got a lot of self-love I am the
prize I am a 10 like let's let's bring
back average let's bring back being
humble let's bring back humility your
pounds looks good I would be canceled I
would the internet would explode because
it's not about health it's never been
about health it's always been about
beauty standards and depression for
capitalistic gain
well he did she did bad shame me as a
child but unlike you yeah shout out mom
I want to give a big shout out to my
mother
um who did Fat shame me as a child and I
lost weight shout out mom shout out if
you care about your kid you'll fat shame
them ask people
the only week
person that she's referring to is
herself because people who are quote
unquote strong because of what they went
through just haven't addressed or dealt
with their trauma
hahaha
my headphones fell off you know what you
haven't dealt with your eating habits
your eating habits that's what needs to
be dealt with freaking my trauma all
these big chicks trying to talk about
how I need therapy when 90 of you are
currently in therapy and have been for
five years because you're not happy and
instead of losing weight you just blame
the world for your problems and
screaming everyone else to find you
attractive and now I'm the bad guy
because I pointed out that you can't get
the guys you like because you are
overweight and that's a shame because a
lot of y'all have pretty faces and you
just ruin them I'm being fat they've
stuffed it in their mind somewhere in
some filing cabinet far far away so that
they don't have to address it
and then what happened put the fork down
put the fork down is if she developed a
narcissistic personality type disorder
oh God now she's a narcissist it's like
these are all the excuses they give to
their exes he's toxic he's insecure he's
a narcissist like I hear you I hear
women give me these same things on my
show they're just talking about their
ex-boyfriends but I guess it's just like
whenever they look bad that's what they
like to do what it is is they will keep
that he's ugly anyway he's medium ugly
so that whenever something happens they
can pull that back out and say well I
was a victim too I was bullied but you
know what I was strong yeah yeah I was
no you are weak-minded because the very
thing that you have in it okay what's
stronger let's just uh let's just go
through this real quick two fat kids
okay if one fat kid won a fat kid too
fat kid one is bullied for being fat and
decides to eat more and get more obese
fat kid 2 is bullied for being fat and
she says you know I'm gonna put the fork
down I'm gonna make some changes and
they're right I am fat let me fix it I
don't know you decide let me know in the
comments very thing that will trigger
you one day
so another person I cannot stand who is
on this [ __ ] app is just pearly
things or whatever the [ __ ] her name is
that little bit she's seriously has some
problems number you think she's married
I'm just curious she has a confidence
problem
um she clearly has none because she
makes fun of people 24 7 who are fat
saying they don't deserve love why she
put quotes like fat
[Laughter]
I'm blessing these people
gin
delusional women this is why people be
like oh did you see the videos about you
no because you see what this does to me
I'm not offended I just like it hurts to
have to watch this much stupidity if
they don't deserve a man who makes six
figures a year what the [ __ ] what kind
of [ __ ] is that that's [ __ ] yet she
looks like [ __ ] Larry Bird and she's
talking
me and Larry Bird could be cousins
[Music]
but ma'am Don't make me say it please
don't
please I don't deserve
then she comes over I don't want to get
taken down for harassment or bullying
but I'm just curious guys smash your
pants
smash or pass
pass okay I was just you never know
maybe she's the hotter one I don't know
come was after lizzo really
uh just for research purposes lizzo
smash your path what about after five
drinks okay what about last woman on the
planet
[Laughter]
blessing says he said I guess the human
race doesn't do
excuse me
is a [ __ ] queen that [ __ ] will get
up there play the flute twerk not even
Melissa's talented but come on can we
just come on out of breath and you're
talking about her health status let me
tell you a little story
I'm a nurse and uh one time I cared for
this lady who was a paraplegic would you
like to know how she became a paraplegic
she had an eating disorder she was
um bulimic this is another tactic women
do
they always do the exception to the rule
with some really bad sob story you won't
get me on this one you won't look it
what percent of obese women are
paraplegics that became obese because
they were paraple or what what percent
of America is anorexic
and her and her boyfriend were riding a
motorcycle
she fell off the back of the motorcycle
because she had a heart attack from
being [ __ ] bulimic
so
size of somebody's body does not always
correlate to health
you cannot look at somebody and tell
if they have poor health it actually
concerns me how many nurses say this 300
is a lot because you think you can
doesn't mean that you can and you're
constantly spreading your [ __ ] about
how fat people are So Unworthy well
[ __ ] I think you're [ __ ] unworthy
that's what I think you claim let me
just cry
I'll never find much
okay okay be Christian well what if I
said all the tall lanky redheaded ugly
[ __ ] didn't deserve love that
wouldn't be very nice now would it and I
wouldn't say that because I'm not a
[ __ ] and you could you could I wouldn't
even be just do a poll do a poll with
the audience who would you rather smash
me or her
[Music]
so my point being you are disgusting why
would you go around spreading that [ __ ]
on an app for like kids number one so
when a little 12 year old girl sees your
video and then starts making herself
[ __ ] throw up because you told her
she's not worthy why do I have to jump
to throwing up I swear to God I was
overweight when I was 12. so it's like
if a 12 year old saw my video and wanted
to lose weight they don't have to throw
up they could just eat less and exercise
I've never told anyone to throw up but
you think kids shouldn't eat healthy and
I'm sorry if your kids are overweight
that's on you as a parent that's on you
you control the food you control their
money you control everything
the only people who agree with the [ __ ]
you say are little 13 year old boys
that's it that is it okay hold on hold
on what my manager uh what percent of my
audience is 13 year old boys yeah very
small I think the majority of my
audience is between like 25 to 37 or
40.9 yeah so 0.9 of my audience is 13.
so 13 to
17.9 you say lizzo can't be happy
because she doesn't have a family some
people don't want a family and that's
okay now I said Liza wasn't happy
because she's like crying on Instagram
every other day I just feel like happy
people don't do that I don't know I'm
not a detective okay I'm not I I could
be wrong but the happiest people I know
like do Happy People you guys now cry on
Instagram no no I don't know maybe
you're I'm probably wrong oh and then
she's gonna be 60 and have health
problems [ __ ] shut up you could have a
[ __ ] health problem tomorrow somebody
might smack you in your mouth
why did you do this to me um okay guys
if you like to see me get tortured
people ask me why I don't watch my hate
videos
unless I'm paid to for a reaction video
then I will
blessing for losing his job today for
torturing me
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
um if we get to 10 000 was it 15 000
likes we will do a part three um but
honestly you need to motivate me to
torture me this much so like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible